Bon dia! La volta al món a peu, dia 263.
Bueno, cap problema amb gossos, només problemes sonors, com sempre.
Una nit tranquil·la, bé de temperatura, m'he pogut tapar, tot sec, inclús la tenda.
I res, seguir caminant, back on the road, let's go, com us agrada.
Les 8 i quart, com heu vist al pla anterior, no porto les polaines avui.
Ahir tampoc les portava, vaig decidir no posar-les perquè, bueno, donen una mica de calor, no gaire, però una mica sí.
I com no camino per terreny molt pedregós, sinó més aviat asfalt i tal, bueno,
en aquest moment no les poso, així també.
A veure, sí, és veritat que em bruta molt al mitjó, perquè sorra i pols hi ha, però estic una mica més ventilat.
Bé, hem arribat a un poble amb bastanta cosa, poble de carretera.
M'ha atropellat el camió.
Clar, el segon restaurant està a uns 15 quilòmetres.
Ara seré moment de caminar, no de parar, però pararé, pararé una estona, encara que no sigui gaire, perquè em ve de gust.
Bona tarda a tots.
Buah, he menjat molt.
Hamburguesa amb patates, està bona, eh?
I les patates ben fetes, eh? I l'hamburguesa també, eh?
Però, ostres, potser aquesta hora no sé si calgui, eh?
Bueno, tu ja han dinat, no?
A veure, per dinar menjaré alguna cosa segur, però això ha sigut l'àpat fort del dia.
Són les 9 de la tarda.
Bueno, pues re, caminant xinutxano. Estem a bastanta altura, ara us posaré aquí l'altitud, i llavors ara toca baixar, malauradament.
Tot el que hem pujat ahir, mil metres, doncs tocarà baixar-los i després tornar a pujar, demà. Bueno, a poc a poc.
I ara, a poc a poc, anem a la resta.
Les 12 i mitja, com pica el sol.
Bé, aquí tenim una intersecció.
El camí es divideix entre aquesta carretera que puja cap a dalt
i aquesta altra carretera que voreja per aquí,
que podem veure la muntanya, la muntanya, la muntanya,
i després més enllà.
La carretera que va cap a dalt és tan nova
que no surt ni al Google Maps.
Bé, aquesta és la meva suposició.
Aquesta és la meva suposició de per què no surt al Google Maps,
per què és massa nova, no ho sé.
El fet és que no entenc molt bé per què l'han fet,
m'haurien d'explicar.
El mapi sí que surt, i el mapi surt que hi ha bastants túnels,
per tant, no aniré per aquí, sinó aniré a la carretera de baix.
I són bastant paral·leles, una va pel mig,
això d'aquests túnels i tal, i l'altra va per aquí baix.
Suposo que, no ho sé, aquesta aquí baix tenia poc ampla,
era, no ho sé, massa incòmoda pels camions,
potser era massa cara d'eixamplar,
i tenia problemes de sellevissaments, és la meva suposició.
I van dir, mira, saps què?
Fem una nova per aquest tram i ja està, més ampla.
No ho sé.
Qualsevol cas, torna a ajuntar-se d'aquí a 60 quilòmetres,
més o menys, de borra.
Doncs seguirem per aquí.
Ara hi ha sí que molts ciclistes, eh?
Bueno, molts. Avui n'he trobat quatre.
Messi, yes?
No.
Ronaldo, yes?
Yes!
Ok, my friend, goodbye.
Què? No.
Rahmat, rahmat.
Que encara m'intoxicarem.
No, que encara m'intoxicarem aquesta.
Rahmat, rahmat.
No, no, no.
A mi m'agrada la sopa aquesta, eh?
Però, clar, ui, ara em seguiran tres quilòmetres d'aquí.
Molt del Madrid, aquí, pel que veig, eh?
Al final m'ha entafurat l'ampolla igualment.
Crec que no me la prendré, però, bueno, he dit, va, he comès l'error.
He comès l'error de treure la cartera,
treure un bitllet de 10 soms, que és un euro,
i, bueno, error, error, perquè ja s'han tornat locos.
Tots els nens, dóna-me-la a mi, dóna-me-la a mi.
I, ostres, però a qui l'hi dono?
I, bueno, al final hi ha un parell que han assenyalat a un d'ells,
que suposo que és el que porta les comptes,
i l'he donat a ell, i ja està.
He llançat l'ampolla.
He arribat al poble aquest, que té tant arbres i està tan així verd.
La calor fa la mateixa o més.
M'agradaria parlar, ai, parlar, hòstia, calla.
M'agradaria parar a algun lloc,
imprescindible que estigui o a l'ombra, ombra, ombra, ben ombra,
o que tingui aire acondicionat.
Preferiblement lo segon.
Doncs, mira, al final he acabat a un restaurant d'empanadilles.
Bueno, això ho vaig menjar ja el primer dia que vaig entrar a Tajikistan.
Ho he ensenyat al vídeo.
Estava bastant bo i no l'havia menjat fins llavors.
És una espècie d'això, d'empanadilla,
amb carn a dintre, i ceba, i espècies, està molt bo.
Com veieu, no tinc aire acondicionat, però tinc ventilador, que bueno, està bé.
I això, això ho fan al forn aquest tipus tandoori, que el posen cap per baix.
I clar, l'acaben de treure i està molt calent.
Llavors, he fet un parell de mossegades i després me'l segueixo menjant.
Bueno, tu, avui, avui...
Més difícil que ahir, eh?
Ahir ja va ser difícil, però avui més.
Jo crec que perquè em falta una mica més d'energia.
Xxxt!
Vaig gastar-ne tot.
Vaig gastar-ne tot ahir.
Són les tres de la tarda.
Porto una bona estona a aquest banc, que està a l'ombra, passa una mica d'airet.
Sincerament, tinc zero ganes d'aixecar-me i posar-me a caminar, eh família?
Dic família?
És que jo no us dic mai, eh?
Tipo, un nom, no?
Hi ha un que segueixo que sempre diu família als seus seguidors.
Potser s'hauria de posar un nom.
Enriquers, què passa, Enriquers?
No.
No cal.
Però la veritat sí, és que la calor és molt heavy, eh?
A més, estic cansat.
Porto 22 km avui, a veure si puc arribar als 35, que és el mínim que m'estic plantejant.
Però d'aquí no em moc, eh?
No, no, no, encara no.
S'està massa bé.
Tinc una mica d'aigua amb gas freda.
De fet, és una casa en particular, eh?
Crec.
Perquè hi ha aquella porta oberta i he entrat...
He vist aquest banc.
Quedo quieto.
M'he dignat a posar-me a caminar i ara estic a la carretera aquesta, que no passa ningú,
perquè tothom va a l'altra, a la nova, no?
Aquí suposo que abans venien tots els camions i, bueno, s'enténs una mica perquè han fet
l'altra.
Mireu quins...
Aquí quins...
Bueno, quins talusos han fet.
I aquí...
Hi ha molta més opció de deixar per la carretera perquè ja tens el riu.
Sí, sí, sí, sí.
A més, bueno, ja veieu...
A més, bueno, ja veieu com hi ha alguns trams així mal pavimentats i tal.
Però bueno, tot supertranquil.
Estic sol.
Ostres!
Prohibit passar.
No sé, encara serà que han fet l'altra carretera perquè aquesta no té sortida perquè hi ha
hagut alguna javissada i potser a peu tampoc la puc travessar, eh?
Ara que estic aquí...
No sé.
Jo segueixo el mapa i no sortia que estava tallada.
Me'n refio bastant de l'aplicació aquesta.
Segueixo per aquí.
És que mirant això tampoc m'estranyaria, eh?
Mireu aquí.
Quines javissades.
Ara, quan he gravat aquest últim vídeo, m'he espantat una mica.
Ai, ai, ai.
Torno a mirar el mapa.
Sense connexió perquè evidentment en aquest congost no hi ha cobertura.
Molt important.
Sempre que aneu a caminar heu de portar algun mapa al mòbil sense que no hi hagi cap cobertura.
No hi ha cap cobertura.
Jo, malauradament, no em paguen per fer publicitat d'aquesta aplicació.
Però, bueno, ho dic igualment.
És l'aplicació Mapi.
Ho vaig intentar.
Bueno, no jo, sinó un dels meus seguidors sense que jo ho demanés.
Va escriure a Mapi i els va dir.
Ei, podíeu patrocinar aquest noi.
Vaig enfadar una amiga me'n va dir.
Vaig dir.
Van pensar.
Ehem, qui és aquest seguidor?
Perquè el vaig dir.
Home, noi...
Tu, tu...
Sense el meu permís.
Tu li vas a parlar de mi a altres marques?
Però bueno.
No, no va sorgir...
Aquesta col·laboració.
Em van donar un codi de...
De descompte.
Bueno, un codi per tenir l'aplicació gratis.
¿Que menys?
És que.
Jo vaig tenir...
Jo vaig fer un vídeo, que está en el canal de YouTube.
Que té molt...
10 mil l'haveria dit.
Té moltes més visualitzacions.
No sé si quinze mil o dieu oit mil o vint mil.
explicant com funciona l'aplicació aquesta
i gràcies a mi, a aquest vídeo
molts de vosaltres heu descarregat
i pagat aquesta aplicació
es pot fer servir gratis, però bueno
hi ha l'opció de pagament
mapa offline
sí, hi ha alguns pobles aquí a prop
o sigui, en aquesta vall, cosa que em tranquil·litza
i a més, ara heu vist que passava un cotxe
doncs he vist que passava un altre, llavors bueno
em tranquil·litza una mica
per altra banda, llavors no sé per què posen aquesta senyal
però bueno, és Tajikistan, tu
aquí funciona així
males notícies
patacada històrica
acaba de passar un cotxe dels que baixaven
i m'ha dit que està tancat
i li he dit
però caminant també, i diu sí
i ara ha passat un home caminant
bueno, és que no ens entenem en anglès
però sí, sí, també m'ha dit que tancant
però que
m'ha fet entendre, crec que
una javissada o alguna cosa
i si pujo alguna d'aquestes muntanyes
i faig així, a peu puc superar
aquesta javissada i seguir
ara tornar enrere és
és un
no són tants qui van a tres
però
ah
és que ho intentaré tu
ho intentaré
sí
a veure què hi ha
a veure què hi ha, no ho sé
un embassament
l'embassament estava previst
estava al mapa, però el que no m'esperava jo
és que comencés tan aviat
jo crec que està més ple del
del que hi ha al mapa
ah
i on està?
la carretera, perquè clar, jo el que veig és
que la carretera hauria d'anar per aquí
i no va, se l'ha menjat l'embassament
la carretera, podria ser
ostres
no, no, si és això
ara ho hauré de mirar, però si és això
ni és javissada
ni d'això, això no sé com
això és impossible de travessar, no?
bua, xaval
heavy això, eh
això és molt fort
no ho havia vist mai
que fort
doncs bé, allà hi havia una família
una dona parlava l'anglès
i la possibilitat d'anar per les muntanyes
de Cristeixters, com deia l'home aquell
s'ha d'agafar una carretera que està marcada
al mapa, que puja fins a un petit poble que hi ha aquí
d'unes cases
i després seguir per un camí que no marca
el mapa
i simplement anar per les muntanyes que potser no hi ha ni camí
i tornar a enllaçar
amb el poble de després
que no me'n recordo el nom
sí
l'altra possibilitat seria simplement anar a camí a través
per aquí
però crec que és una mica massa
empinat
fins que la carretera tornés a sorgir
és l'opció més
més curta però no necessàriament
la més ràpida
el problema
d'anar per aquesta desviació
és que, bueno, avui
no arribaria al següent poble
bueno, no tindria aigua
ara em podria carregar
hauria de carregar
i...
sí, sí, sí
i bueno, un contratemps
i demà hauria de tornar
a enxampar el poble
i bueno, seria pujada
i tampoc està molt clar
quin seria el camí, saps?
i sense cobertura
no puc mirar la pista satèl·lit
que a vegades t'ajuda a trobar, saps?
ai, ai, ai
l'opció més fàcil seria tornar enrere
i anar per la carretera amb túnels, no?
però crec que ja estic massa
ficat a dintre d'aquí com per tornar enrere
uns 2,2 quilòmetres
per aquesta carretera
no, camí
amb pujada
i després a preguntar
i arrasar
ara porto una estona pujant
mira, aquella pista
no l'havia vist pas, però mira
pum, pum, pum
vosaltres creieu que segueix
cap a l'altra banda de la muntanya
i segueix fins a arribar a la carretera
o simplement
és per
arribar fins a aquell pal
no ho sé, però ara mateix està
complicat agafar-la
no, és qüestió de parlar amb algun habitant millor
que em digui vés per aquí, vés per allà
és el millor
doncs res, he arribat fins al final del poble
i aquestes persones tan simpàtiques
m'han donat aigua
bueno, aigua amb iogurt
allò que l'altre abans estava dient que no vull beure
doncs bueno, com m'han donat han sigut molt simpàtics
però m'han dit
que no, que no segueixi per aquí
hi ha un altre que m'ha dit que sí, eh
és a dir
m'he trobat un home
amb aquell cotxe gegant que he vist que anava supercarregat
que m'ha dit que sí, que podia tal
que m'ha dit que sí, que podia anar tirant cap a dalt
i que, bueno, com m'ho ha dit, eh
i aquest home que hi ha aquí al cotxe davant meu
m'ha dit també
que sí, però
aquest m'ha dit que no
igualment, sí, jo crec que sí que es podria
crec que sí que es podria, però
espera que ara
aquest home m'ha intentat ajudar
amb el traductor, a veure què em diu ara
el que m'ha dit aquest bon home és que ja és tard
i que si volia podria quedar-me a casa seva
a dormir, superamable
i sí que és veritat que és una mica tard
són les
6 menys quart, però
hi ha la possibilitat de
si jo arribo a baix, potser trobo
algun cotxe que em porta
fins a Obigarm
que és el poble on he dinat
i després tornar a fer autostop
i tornar a la intersecció
per anar ja per la carretera
perquè sí, sí, sí, em retiro
em retiro
de rota monumental
no sé, jo crec que hauria pogut, però
massa incerteses
o sigui, al mapa no hi ha camins
ara podria agafar aigua, però
no hi ha aigua probablement durant tot el camí
i qui sap
si arribo on pretenc arribar
i
i no, no, i hi ha pantano
i no hi ha camins, saps, jo què sé
jo què sé
bueno, això és un
mal planificat, vull dir
m'ha passat el meu orgull
entre cometes, i quan estava a baix
quan he trobat la carretera tancada
hi havia dos cotxes allà
que m'haguessin pogut portar
un altre cop fins a Obigarm, o fins i tot el primer cotxe
que m'ha dit, no, no es pot passar
sabeu, el primer cotxe que m'ha dit així, no es pot passar
aquí s'ha ofert a portar-me
també fins a Obigarm amb cotxe
i he dit, hòstia, no, per no
tornar enrere, ja estaria allà
i ja hagués començat el camí
què perdo
amb això de temps, bueno, ja ho veurem
però
un dia sencer podria ser
perquè dubte que
potser demà al matí
o demà al migdia arribo a la intersecció
on puc tornar a agafar la carretera amb els túnels, però
un dia sencer pot ser que el perdi
sí, sí, bastant
bastant, bastant
toca d'allò, no sé si
en el tema del track, com ho faré, perquè clar
tornant enrere així i tal, si ara agafo un cotxe
perquè espero que hi hagi un cotxe
és que si no
si he de tornar caminant fins a Obigarm
ja és la liada màxima, és molt possible
perquè, clar
ara no hi haurà cap cotxe aquí
i demà al matí a primera hora tampoc hi haurà ningú
bueno
doncs el que faré serà, doncs, parar el track
i a l'estrava té l'opció
de retallar, té l'opció de retallar
llavors, retallaré el track
fins a la intersecció i demà
quan la torri a enganxar, tornaré a engegar el track
és el que hi ha
bueno Enric, no passa res, és un dia
ja, ja, ja, home, un dia és
és bastant, tenint en compte tot el que estic dient aquests dies
que vaig cur de temps
per arribar al Pamir
i totes aquestes històries
bueno
ja està, ja està, no passa res
no passa res, som-hi
doncs he arribat a baix
jo pensant que havia fet una ultramarató
des d'Ovigram
doncs resulta que només eren
no arriba ni a 6 km, per tant
doncs podria anar ara mateix
caminant, però veig que hi ha dos cotxes
aquí, llavors a veure si algun
d'aquests que m'estan mirant
fixament em poden
portar
allà
doncs ja està, tu
m'han portat fins aquí
i saps què?
em quedo a un hotel, bueno, hotel
o com se li digui això que tinc aquí al darrere
sí, sí, tu, ja està
avui he estat vençut una altra vegada
Tadjikistan m'ha vençut
és la segona vegada que m'ha vençut
bueno, que és que aquí es podia suposar que
la carretera acabaria
a un llac, a un embassament
una ja avisada encara, però un embassament
bueno tu, vaig a l'habitació
a dutxar-me
i amics
aquests racons de món, això no és la meva
habitació, la meva habitació tenia lavabo
però no hi ha aigua al lavabo, no hi ha aigua corrent
i m'han portat a un altre
edifici proper aquí
que jo suposo que són uns banys, no sé
comunals del poble o algo
i hi ha aquestes dues banyeres
no us preocupeu que no em banyaré a la banyera
però hi ha la dutxa aquesta també
i aquí
aquí és on em dutxaré
una tovallola
sabó, sort que en tinc
roba de recanvi també, però
ai, Enric et venç just
pitjor habitació
de la història, l'habitació en si
dius, bueno
humil, petita
no, però clar
el fet que no hi hagi aigua al lavabo
a part que hi ha, no sé, perquè hi ha ampolles
allà i coses
i està ple de pols
és a dir, he caminat ara per aquest terra
i notava els preus
crec, crec, saps, quan he caminat
sense el calçat
que menys que tenir pols, no?
jo crec que aquest lloc està tancat
me l'han obert a mi, perquè han dit
bueno, anem a fer negoci amb el guir aquest
m'han cobert 5 euros, eh, només, també és la més barata
de la volta del món a peu, però
i el que a mi em toca més, les pilotes, perquè
bueno, dic, bueno, dutxar-me, ja m'he dutxat allà
igual, és això
l'aire acondicionat, funciona
funciona perquè l'he endollat
i ha fet pip, tal, però el tio
no m'ha volgut donar el
mando, diu, no, no, no, ja
bueno, no sé què m'ha dit, però que no, que no, que no
i fa calor
és que lo curiós és que a fora
aquesta hora s'està perfecta
aquí, s'està molt bé
tu a dintre
no corre l'aire, fa calor
a més acampat, eh
arribo a saber i acampo
bueno, avui
31 km, mira, el que veureu
ara en pantalla és
el que seria, el que he fet
vale, el que he fet, a l'estrava
veureu la versió
retallada, la versió legal
entre cometes, vale, però aquí veieu el que he fet
eh, a més
ha pogut ser un bon dia, la veritat
bastant tranqui, pel congost aquest
pum, pum, pum, he passat una mica
de calor, però també he anat descansant
però aquest final
aquest final que podria haver sigut final
per l'hotel, però
tot malament, tot malament
després, amb gent amb qui he
parlat, doncs, bueno, avui bastantes, eh
avui posa-li, posa-li
5 o 6, i de calés
és complicat perquè vaig pagant en efectiu
saps, i és difícil, posa-li 10
no, posa-li 12
amb l'hotel aquest posa-li 12
cafès i test, res
bueno, tu, demà
intentaré arribar al punt de sortida
ja sigui a peu o amb autostop
o amb taxi
i tornem
pels túnels, que els túnels
n'hi ha un de 3 km, el que passa és que
no serà demà, serà demà passat perquè és un tram
de 60 km, llavors
en tinc per dos dies, vinga
Enric Adventures, avui més que mai